consideremos la siguiente historia
vov está en una habitación y tiene dos
monedas una moneda legal y una moneda
con dos caras toma aleatoriamente una de
ellas la lanza al aire
y grita el resultado
cara ahora cuál es la probabilidad de
que haya tirado la moneda legal para
responder esta pregunta sólo necesitamos
retroceder y hacer un árbol en el primer
evento toma una de dos monedas entonces
de nuestro árbol crecen dos ramas que
conducen a dos resultados que son
igualmente probables es decir moneda
legal o falsa en el siguiente evento
lanza la moneda al aire y el árbol crece
de nuevo si tiene la moneda legal
sabemos que puede haber dos resultados
igualmente probables cara o cruz
mientras que para la moneda falsa puede
haber dos resultados ambos caras
hemos terminado nuestro árbol y podemos
ver que tiene cuatro hojas que
representan cuatro resultados igualmente
probables
el paso final nueva evidencia bob dice
cara una vez que obtenemos nueva
evidencia debemos recortar nuestro árbol
cortamos cualquier rama que nos dirija a
cruz porque sabemos que el resultado no
fue cruz y ya está la probabilidad de
que bob haya tomado la moneda legal es
el único resultado legal que conduce a
cara dividido entre tres posibles
resultados que conducen la cara y un
tercio
qué pasa si lanza la moneda de nuevo y
grita cara recuerda que nuestro árbol
crece después de cada evento las hojas
de la moneda legal representan dos
resultados que son igualmente probables
cara o cruz las hojas de la moneda falsa
son dos resultados igualmente probables
cara o cara después de escuchar el
segundo cara cortamos todas las ramas
que nos conduzcan a cruz y por lo tanto
la probabilidad de que la moneda sea
legal después de dos caras consecutivas
es el único resultado legal que conduce
a un cara dividido entre todos los
posibles resultados que conducen a cara
con un quinto podemos observar que
nuestra confianza en que hayamos sacado
la moneda legal está disminuyendo
conforme obtenemos más caras sin embargo
nunca será cero
no importa cuántas veces se lance la
moneda nunca podremos estar 100% seguros
de que la moneda es falsa de hecho todas
las preguntas de la probabilidad
condicional se pueden responder con
ayuda de árboles hagamos uno más para
estar seguros bob tiene tres monedas dos
son legales
y la otra está cargada es decir se le
agrega peso para que caiga karam dos
tercios de las veces y caiga cruz un
tercio de las veces elige una moneda al
azar y la lanza al aire
cara ahora cuál es la probabilidad de
que haya elegido la moneda cargada
retrocedamos
y construyamos el árbol
el primer evento es elegir la moneda lo
que nos da tres resultados igualmente
probables moneda legal moneda legal y
moneda cargada en el siguiente evento es
lanzar la moneda cada moneda legal nos
da dos hojas que son igualmente
probables cara o cruz la moneda cargada
nos da tres hojas que son igualmente
probables dos representan cara y una
representa cruz ahora el truco es
asegurarnos de que el árbol esté
balanceado lo que significa una misma
cantidad de hojas creciendo de cada rama
para hacer esto debemos aumentar el
número de ramas al mínimo común múltiplo
que para 2 y 3 es 6
finalmente etiquetamos nuestras hojas
nuestras monedas legales ahora nos dan
seis hojas cada una que son igualmente
probables tres caras y tres cruces para
la moneda cargada tenemos dos hojas con
cruz y cuatro hojas con cara y ya está
cuando bob grita el resultado cara nos
da una nueva evidencia y podemos cortar
las ramas que nos llevan a cruz porque
sabemos que no resultó cruz así que la
probabilidad de que haya elegido la
moneda cargada dado que obtuvo karam
bueno tenemos cuatro hojas en la moneda
cargada que dividimos entre todas las
hojas posibles cuatro decimos un 40%
en caso de duda siempre es posible
responder las preguntas de probabilidad
condicional con el teorema de valles
este teorema nos da la probabilidad del
evento a dada una nueva evidencia p
aunque si lo olvidas no te preocupes
solo necesitas saber cómo contar
historias con árboles podados